[Music]
I actually impressed it already huh the
walk button night I pressed it
couldn't hurt to press it again but it
won't help I mean I pressed it already
right already done you don't think I
didn't press it no I wasn't saying that
good so I most certainly did press it
something wait for the to change
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm like late for work so press it what
for why would you do something that's
already done I mean I just think that
that's crazy right I don't know you
wouldn't suit up and try to kill bin
Laden again it's done I have killed the
bin Laden of pressing this button how
long ago did you press it what do you
think I've been standing here for days I
just trust it right as you walked up are
you sure you pressed it am I sure I
pressed it it's copper Atmos rats know
how to press buttons do you think I'm
dumber than a rat no no nobody's doing
anything like that it's gonna change
just just wait it's because I trust it
already okay no offense I'm just gonna
press it what would you do that for this
is precision equipment designed by
people with engineering degrees it will
work I pressed it sir
I pressed the button while we've been
standing here the light cycle has gone
by twice okay I'm not saying you didn't
press it I'm just saying maybe it didn't
work if it didn't work for me why in the
world would it work for you you think
you think if it would change faster if
you who pressed it do you think the
light doesn't like me or something well
do you think that this particular button
was designed so that it only works at
the same time that has been pressed
lunacy okay deej understands do not
check my balls on this one okay
please okay fine we'll just stand here
thank you
what
you shouldn't press the button hold it
up dude
no outside I already pressed the button
you
you